hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion over 230 years
through world wars the rise and fall of
nations and industries
revolutions and uprisings bearings bank
persevered
founded in 1762 bering's bank was an
english institution
associated with class longevity and
strength
so much so that even the queen of
england had an account with them
then in 1995 this grand banking legacy
was destroyed
brought down by a single rogue trader by
the name of nick leeson
[Music]
so let's explore how a 28-year-old from
hertfordshire
was able to single-handedly destroy an
[Music]
[Music]
nick leeson was born in watford
hedfordshire to a middle-class home
he was a confident but unimpressive
student despite his average educational
performance
he was eventually able to secure a job
with morgan stanley
he worked in their futures and options
department giving support to the traders
on the front line
in 1989 two years after starting with
morgan stanley
nick leeson approached his supervisor
and asked to be promoted
leeson wanted to be a trader and he felt
that he deserved the promotion
unfortunately his manager didn't agree
and the request was turned down
but leeson knew what he wanted and
subsequently
he quit morgan stanley on his quest to
become a stock trader
he would come across bering's bank and
send in his application
apparently he'd never heard of the bank
before submitting the application
at that stage i probably would be happy
to say that i'd never heard of bearings
but it was a famous old man so
there's no bearings in watford bearings
was no ordinary bank
it catered to the most affluent class of
people
in the banking industry the bearing's
name was respected
it was the safest of all banks and they
could raise capital very easily
though behind the scenes its operations
were struggling to keep up with the
modern banking world
leeson described the securities trading
department of bearings as being in stark
contrast to modern banks like morgan
stanley
just a totally different environment
there was um
you know morgan stanley everything was
it was new
you know all of the equipment was new um
the furniture was new
bearings everything is you know just
tacky i suppose i can't describe it any
other way
from his position as one of the bank's
bookkeepers it didn't take him very long
to find flaws in how the bank operated
bering's bank was crumbling during a
time when most other financial
institutions were thriving
feeding on the good standing that comes
with two centuries of global trading
it would survive though much like it
always had
but what bearings wouldn't survive would
be hiring nick
leeson
while many in the industry including
leeson possessed the intelligence to
succeed
leeson also had a confidence and a way
with people that he would wield like a
secret weapon
he was charming friendly and personable
to his colleagues
but not just for the sake of being
polite he saw his co-workers not as
potential companions but rather a means
to an end
despite working at banks for multiple
years he never considered his co-workers
as friends
he did not like them he did not respect
them but he knew
that sometimes he needed them to get
what he wanted
it's very easy for me to get on with
people but i don't necessarily have to
like you
or any of the people that i work with to
get on with them so i can i come in i do
my job i do it to the best of my ability
and then at the end of the day if you're
going to ask me out for a drink i'm not
going to go out for a drink with you
because i don't like you nick leeson
impressed his superiors at bearings with
his keen eye for identifying and solving
issues within the bank
not long into his employment he was sent
overseas to chase down massive sums of
money
these were debts that were long overdue
but never followed up on
bering's bank had a habit of making
deals that would fall between the cracks
and it was nick leeson's fresh eyes that
would hunt down these deals
and claim back what the bank was owed
leeson managed to find close to 100
million pounds
the equivalent of twice of that today
when factoring inflation
he describes this kind of mismanagement
as being fairly typical for bearings
things were looking good for leeson he
was impressing his employees
and while in jakarta he met a fellow
bearing staff member by the name of lisa
sims
for the first time in his career he
found a colleague that he genuinely
liked and in 1992
the two of them married that same month
his years of hard work finally paid off
when berings offered him the position of
a trader he would be in charge of a
newly founded futures division
in singapore this was the opportunity
that leeson had been waiting for and
quite possibly the worst decision that
bearings had ever made
approved to trade in singapore and
having convinced his wife lisa to move
it was go time trading primarily on the
nikkei
japan's top 225 company stock index
nick thoroughly enjoyed the stress and
pressure of features trading
essentially betting on if the price will
rise or fall
if the market went the way he predicted
he made money
if not he rapidly lost money
he was confident in himself and beloved
by his staff
but later that year the market began
fluctuating violently
and leeson's team started making
mistakes these bad bets were adding up
and if they weren't rectified
bearings stood to lose large sums of
money
out of the fear of losing the job that
he worked so hard to obtain
and fuelled by his own self-confidence
nick
decided to hide the losing bets from his
employers back home
in order to do this he altered the
software of a separate hidden account so
that his bosses in england couldn't keep
track
he named this account the five eighths
so account kept his losing trades active
but hidden
he assumed that inevitably he'd be able
to cancel out the losses with future
wins
but there was only one problem with this
margin payments
while the losing trades remained open
payments still had to be made in order
to keep the trades going
he was going to need external funding he
just needed enough money to keep the
failed trades going and when the market
turned around
he'd be home free leeson would hide his
mistakes
and then when the market went his way he
would fix his mistakes in private
nick had to keep digging into a deeper
pit of lies
his bosses over in england could never
find out what happened
he asked his superiors for funds to
cover stock futures that he bought for
clients
only this time the clients didn't exist
trusting that leeson had the bank's best
interests in mind the branch over in
england happily sent him ever-increasing
amounts of money
without ever thinking to double check
where the money was
actually going surprisingly for a time
the system worked leeson described
living with the lies as easy
after the first two days from the first
time i do anything
i'm not expecting to survive anymore
anything more than two days
to me it's obvious if they can't see it
after two days then
who says they're going to see it after
200 days 500 days a thousand days
you don't get confident but you you're
getting away with it
as nick leeson continued to cover up his
trading mistakes
bearings itself was making massive
losses and that was just the amount they
knew about
something had to be done so they
recruited peter norris
he was to oversee operations
from the moment he began looking at the
bank's records norris was shocked at
what he found
the books were a mess how shocked were
you by the lack of control
in that when you got in there and began
to work there
i was shocked um
because i didn't feel that it should
have been
allowed to to reach that point
he saw a bank on the brink of collapse
with ever-increasing debt and a loose
grip on its standing as a powerful
player in the financial world
he brought in a team to clean up the
mess but the dire situation that shocked
norris
was merely a fraction of the problem he
was yet to find
the hidden account in singapore that
would eventually collapse the entire
bank
meanwhile leeson's plan to gradually
cover his losses and emerge victorious
had not gone to plan
by the end of 1992 his losses had only
grown
now amounting to four million pounds
seeing no way out there was only one
thing to do
gamble even harder going against the
bank's rules
he bought hundreds of additional futures
in hopes of covering his losses
he bought so many orders that if the
market was to move in his favor it would
completely wipe out his debt
he believed he could make his money back
without anyone ever finding out what he
had done
at this point he was struggling to sleep
at night
but surprisingly it worked by july of
1993 he had covered his losses
leeson described the past nine months as
a living nightmare
but he had done it and come out
relatively unscathed
unfortunately for all involved leeson
had not learned his lesson
in fact what he had learned was how to
commit fraud and get away with it
rather than take away a valuable lesson
in risk management leeson saw an
opportunity to get filthy rich
nick was convinced by his past successes
that he would eventually be able to
trade out of any amount of losses
and maintain his reputation as an
industry legend
in his mind he was a genius that had
beaten the system
but in reality what had happened was
just dumb luck
meanwhile back in england bearings was
recouping losses and the work of peter
norris was paying off
things were going well and the bank was
recovering but the work wasn't over
so bearings brought in a new head of
in-house trading rob baker
baker was a smart man and he valued
tight oversight
unlike his predecessors he was cynical
of profits that couldn't be easily
accounted for
because of this nick leeson's department
quickly caught his eye
you see bering's bank was paying nick
gleason to fund requests for new clients
and they noticed that some of these
clients who actually in reality didn't
exist were not keeping up with their
fees
an internal audit was ordered and in
july of 1993 the auditors flew to
singapore
by the end of 1993 leeson had found
himself in the same trouble as last time
only this time doubling up his strategy
didn't work
by the time baker came face to face with
leeson his secret account was now hiding
losses of 94 million pounds
nick would sometimes lose a million
pounds in a single day
rob baker saw through leeson's
confidence recognizing a struggling and
immature man
who didn't take too kindly to being
overseen but what he could not have
predicted was what was truly going on
behind the scenes
leeson was now extremely worried he
understood that if the auditors found
just one document referring to the
secret five-eighths account where his
losses were hidden
his entire scheme would unravel but luck
would be in his favor again
as the orders has surprisingly found
nothing
they come in and they don't test any
records
so i can't be happier they didn't test
one record
one report yeah i mean it's not an audit
leeson would later state that it was
general incompetence from the bearing
staff
that allowed him to go on undiscovered
but rob baker has a different
theory nick was supposedly making the
bank a bunch of money
so they didn't bother to question the
fact that nick was both the head of
singapore trading operations
and in charge of the singapore
accounting and despite the strange
accounts not paying any fees
bearings thought hey if it's making us
money
don't fix it
by september of 1994 the secret
five-eighths account was hiding losses
of 160 million pounds
leeson's fraud entered new levels of
complexity
he decided to use the secret account to
buy futures from himself
at extremely discounted prices allowing
him to fake massive profits
nick was now in a deep vicious
unsustainable cycle
it could only continue so long as he had
access to the fund that berings would
send him
for fake clients his life became a
runaway train
in secret he was losing millions daily
but in public
he was becoming the star trader that he
always wanted to be
neither could exist without the other at
this time
leeson became known as the king of the
exchange
he was making a name for himself and had
convinced the world that he was a
success
in december of 1994 leeson was flown to
new york
here berings held a traders conference
and nick was the star
after all according to the records he
had made the bank
28 million pounds that year alone he was
the poster boy of bering's bank
and celebrated for a success but some of
the other traders weren't as excited
they had done their own maths and
something didn't add up
but the bering's bank executives paid no
attention to these doubts
the bank was on the way up it even got
to the stage when nick was asking for
hundreds of thousands of pounds per day
for margin payments
and without question it was given to him
by the end of 1994 based solely on lies
confidently told and expertly hidden
bering's bank had transferred
75 of their entire capital into the
hands of one man
nick leeson 330 million pounds
the pressure had become too much for
leeson and he had finally reached
breaking point
how could he live a lie so massive on a
christmas trip to ireland
he told his wife that he did not want to
return back to singapore
but lisa didn't understand why he would
turn down such a great opportunity for
their family
nick couldn't bring himself to tell her
the truth so
he returned to singapore in the new year
why lie i'm his wife why should he lie
i mean i suppose lots of wives think
that when they find out their husbands
have been having an affair and they
think oh you know they've been leading a
double life
and that's what it feels like not that
with nick's had an effect
feels like nick well nick was leading a
double life
[Music]
there was no economic or political
factors impacting the japanese market
so nick leeson bet on stability and for
a while it was working
for a couple of weeks he was making a
profit as the market remained steady
if this kept going his losses could be
erased and he would be victorious once
again
but on january 17th at 5 46 a.m
a massive earthquake struck the japanese
city of kobe
it killed 6 000 and displaced 45 000
the japanese nikkei stock index in which
nick was trading
absolutely crumbled it was bad you know
um but again it's living to fight
another day
really i mean you know with without the
choice of running away from it you know
i had to um
bearings were still paying me money
don't forget he's still
paying me masses of money you know i
mean we'd ask for sometimes for 100
million dollars they'd pay it
with the market running away from him he
was desperate he made one final bet
buying thousands more futures contracts
in an attempt to prop up the market
he was hoping that this move would be
substantial enough to fight against the
crash
it was another failed gamble in a single
day he lost a further 50 million pounds
but he continued down this path he asked
the bank for more money which they would
provide on the basis of falsified
profits
fictitious profits manufactured from the
secret five-eighths account
while bearings continued to believe
leeson's deception they were happy with
his falsified prophets
and trusted that he was doing well they
believed that he was taking advantage of
the chaotic market since the earthquake
and making huge sums of money for
everyone involved
at one stage auditors found a 50 million
pound loss
that nick forgot to hide frantically
nick forged a bank loan document with
scissors and glue to cover it up
amazingly the auditors believed the
document even though it had
from nick and lisa at the top the fax
signature from their home machine
then finally after all the close calls
audits unimaginable debt and luck both
good
and bad leeson's time was up
on the 17th of february a single clerk
in singapore noticed some discrepancies
in leeson's accounts
and brought them to his attention after
failing to deflect the clerk's enquiries
for a week
he knew that this time he couldn't make
this one go away
feeling that the walls were finally
closing in nick told the clerk that his
wife was unwell
he had to go and visit her and he'd be
back in 45 minutes
of course this was a lie nick
frantically rushed home to collect his
wife
packed up his belongings and they both
drove to the airport and boarded a
flight to a luxury resort in malaysia
that week with nick gone and not being
able to provide any more distractions
the bearings officers from london were
finally able to access one of leeson's
accounts
it was a horrific disaster they knew
straight away
that bankruptcy was inevitable so senior
managers within
bearings bank knew that there were vast
differences between what lisa was asking
for and what you were being given
yeah you were never told yeah
should you have been told yes i should i
should
why didn't you know well fundamentally
because it wasn't raised
in that way why not
i don't know
don't know
bearings appealed to england central
bank for support they were desperate for
a bailout before the markets opened
again on monday
but it wasn't possible leeson's losses
had multiplied to 830 million pounds
the equivalent of 2 billion us dollars
today it was clear that the bank
couldn't be saved after two long
centuries of banking
bearings collapsed
on the 20th of november 1995 leeson was
arrested in germany
and extradited to singapore he was
charged with two counts of deceiving the
bank's auditors
and of cheating the singapore exchange
he received a six and a half year prison
sentence
but he was released after four years for
good behaviour
[Music]
in all of this leeson maintains a
dismissive and blameless attitude
towards the events that caused the crash
in his mind the fault lies with those
who ran bearings and not him
why didn't those people who ran bearings
come to you and say what are you doing
because they're stupid they don't
understand the business and they should
never been in the position that they
were in
especially people like tony horse he was
supposed to be controlling the global
treasury function he was supposed to
understand derivatives he didn't
and he would pay the money every single
day
would accept you know pretty ridiculous
explanations for me it wouldn't happen
at morgan stanley
at variance they had a lot of idiots
basically in every one of the
controlling functions
and you were creating a large amount of
profits
fictitiously yeah it's complete
amazement
but um as you get to know the people at
bearings you can then understand the
amazement
a lot of them are just bumbling fools
although his arrogance is distasteful
the law was inclined to agree with him
the courts found bearings to be
responsible for the deficit in internal
auditing and risk management
their carelessness allowed the fraud to
spiral out of control
but this shouldn't distract from the
fact that hordes of people lost their
jobs
and their money during the bearings
failure
in the fallout from the collapse dutch
bank ing
bought bearings for a single pound they
later sold off various assets
today bearings exists only as a
cautionary tale
a lesson to banks across the globe that
accountability
and careful oversight comes before blind
trust
and the thrill of profits and a reminder
to long-standing institutions
that nothing is eternal
leeson's life has been consistently
strange since his imprisonment
being somewhat of a household name for
older generations he has dipped in and
out of the public eye
even competing in the 2018 season of
celebrity big brother
going into the big brother house we're
going to be in a confined environment
there are things that are going to annoy
me about people i'm sure
he went on the run and became at the
time the world's most wanted man
so at the time it was crazy i was on
every
news channel that you can imagine the
newspapers were all covering the story
interpol were looking for me so wherever
you turned around there was a picture of
me
so that my friends is the wild and
twisting story of nick gleason
a story of how one man got himself into
an ever deeper hole
until he destroyed the oldest bank in
england
so thanks for watching if you enjoyed
the episode be sure to subscribe to cold
fusion
i cover anything in science and
technology business and history
so what do you guys think about this all
let me know in the comments section
below
if you do want to discuss the video a
bit further head on over to the cold
fusion discord
so this has been to go go and you're
watching cold fusion so until next time
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
oh